Let's run through a couple of other funny
clips in the time that we have.
We have a lot to get to today, but there's
a few other things from the last week that
I did not get to that I want to first of all,
here is a CNN host, Chris Cuomo, who invited
Republican senator from Texas, Ted Cruz, on
his program.
And they got into it.
And at one point when Ted Cruz started going
after Chris Cuomo, his brother, Andrew Cuomo.
Chris Cuomo brings up Trump, said, your wife
suddenly.
And of course, it's true.
Recall the story back from the campaign where
Donald Trump did did indeed send out a tweet
saying it, implying saying that Joe Biden.
That's Ted Cruz's wife, not Joe Biden's wife.
Although it wouldn't shock me to hear Trump
talk about Joe Biden's wife, but know that
Ted Cruz's wife is unattractive.
And here is Cruz being interviewed by Chris
Cuomo, mixing it up.
Cruz tries to attack Cuomo over his brother
being Andrew Cuomo.
And Cuomo doesn't.
It doesn't go for a.
Take a look.
Does that make you pause?
Surprise me, Ted.
A lot of guys like you stand by, Rosie.
A mayor like a wise man instead of tying the
president to get on it.
When you have, I'll tell you to get on it.
My father will stand for Islam.
Republic, part of you talk to the president
the way you talked to my brother, Ted.
You afraid of him?
You think he's smacked down at home?
Oh, God.
Try llamas, Yogi.
You guys got really intense.
I'm talking about the president.
My brother, not the president.
The one who called you a liar.
The one who said your wife is ugly.
That guy.
You know, then that guy now won't say anything
about.
I recognize that you like.
You actually wonder why you don't have a lot
of Republicans that want to come on your show.
I have more than any other show and yell at
me and an insult.
I'm not so I'm not yelling at my voice to
match your own because you want to try yelling.
That's all.
People have done that.
That's okay, Chris.
You're perfectly fine to scream and yell because
you know why you don't.
You're doing it because you don't want to
discuss the substance like a hedge.
You invited me on the show to actually talk
about the Supreme Court and talk about the
book One Vote Away.
It is indeed true.
Donald Trump back during the 2016 Republican
primary tweeted out a picture of Ted Cruz's
wife alongside Melania Trump with the message,
A picture is worth a thousand words, very
unflattering image of Ted Cruz's wife.
And eventually Ted Cruz still got in line
and still supported Donald Trump.
And he doesn't want to talk about that incident
now with Chris Cuomo.
There are right wingers that are mad at Cuomo
here.
Good on Chris Cuomo, I say.
And way, way, way to go.
Calling out Ted Cruz.
When Cruz tries to pivot to talking about
Andrew Cuomo, remind him that Trump called
his wife ugly.
And we've talked about this before.
Why is it that these people who trump brutally
and disgustingly attacks even attacking their
families?
How is it they get in line and support Trump?
Is it because they see Trump is the only path
to power and they don't want to be on the
outside?
They're desperate to be on the inside.
Is it that Trump goes to them with some kind
of compelling case that he makes this Trump
apologize to them behind the scenes?
I can't imagine.
I've never seen Trump apologize publicly for
anything ever.
So it's hard to believe.
That's the explanation.
I don't know what it is, but I'm curious to
hear what what you think.
Why do these people that are viciously attacked
by Trump on a personal level?
Right.
I mean, the Comilla Biden thing.
Okay.
Saying Biden was racially insensitive.
It is a personal attack in a sense, because
it goes to who Joe Biden is.
But it was all very clearly politics and about
the things Joe Biden did as as an elected
official, as a legislator, saying your wife
is ugly is is a different caliber.
It's a different game altogether that's being
played.
And Cruz just fell in line and supports Trump
and goes out and does his dirty work.
Let me know what you think explains it